top départ pour les vacances de pâques
et pour beaucoup de parents l'angoissent
des activités pour les enfants et ce
dans un rayon de 10 km défi relevé par
la tourangelle sophie ory sur son compte
instagram mule loire family cette
enseignante en tourisme en lycées
professionnels partagent ses idées à
près de 6000 abonnés aurélie renault l'a
rencontré château vélo rando atelier
cuisine au jardinage voilà comment
sophie remplissez mercredi et ses
week-ends depuis trois ans cette
enseignante partage ses découvertes sur
instagram son compte s'appelle will we
are family et ses complices sont ces
filles nina 13 ans et rose 8 ans
aujourd'hui direction angoisse pour un
jeu de piste
en fait c'est un collectif d'artistes
qui s'appelle papers et qui a eu cette
idée de génie ils ont reproduit des
oeuvres d'art en perles les perles à
repasser que les enfants utilisent et
les ont placés dit fait divers endroits
de la ville donc il ya trente plaques
le défi débute par un escalier
vertigineux attention aux familles qui
ont des poussettes
voilà ce que poste sophie sur son compte
je vais faire une petite vidéo sur mon
essoufflement parce que ben pour aller
jusqu'à la table d'orientation d'envoi
c'est pas ça se mérite
monsieur me disais en basset 155 ch et
après quelques minutes de marche c'est
gagné une première oeuvre en perles est
détecté par la famille près du clos lucé
l'objectif de sophie mélanger le
culturel et le ludique pour ses
followers mais surtout pour ses filles
qui gardent mille et un souvenirs est
allé dans la nuit et un jardin du
château et ben on avait fait une visite
de temps oui aujourd'hui avec la
restriction des 10 km beaucoup de
monuments et sorties ne sont plus
accessibles
mais ne dites pas à sophie et à ses 6000
abonnés qu'il n'y a rien à faire bien au
contraire il ya un site que je veux
découvrir que dans le loir et cher c'est
les sites des sablonnières en fait ce
sont les tranchées d'entraînement de la
guerre 14 18 alors de là on peut dire
les enfants ça va pas tellement les
passionnés des trous dans la terre et
bien si parce que voilà je vais en
profiter pour faire une sortie en forêt
j'espère qu'il aura peut-être des petite
jacinthe voilà ça va vraiment être
une découverte insolite parmi les
followers des tourangeaux mais surtout
beaucoup de franciliens
bientôt le compte instagram proposera
des sorties en sud touraine car le
projet estival de sophie c'est un grand
voyage à bord d'un van